Bethlehem is no little town these days
and it lies now at the heart of a land
of conflict and stalemate intolerance
and division Israel's separation wall
runs right through it but beyond the
wall the Christmas story lives on
for Christians this is where it all
began
[Music]
behind the tree here in manger square is
the fifth century church built on the
spot where Jesus is said to have been
born it was close to collapse six years
ago today this Christmas a small
restoration team have almost completed
their work start on site by the middle
of September 2013 for a fifth - ma it's
beyond a dream a very special moment for
you yes a Christian from Bethlehem and
the manager of a project he never
thought would be possible and it's been
a journey of discovery
angels revealed from behind plaster a
font hidden within another it's a place
that tracks history from Crusader
drawings to the bullet holes of a more
modern conflict you cannot imagine how
much it was great to to expose something
you are touching the history you are
touching one of the holiest places the
worldwide so it is very sensitive and it
was great to work here
I'm sure let's walk on thank you a
survey completed by the British in the
1930s has been critical in the success
of today's restoration we found that
they did perfect documentation report
that allows us to expose again these
areas where it is documented that we
have the floor mosaic a thief has worked
with an Italian firm to carry out the
renovations the funding has been through
donations some from individuals some
from governments around the world we
started with the roof the roof was full
of holes that allows for rainwater to
enter inside the church that damaged the
wooden structure
the roof and all the decorative surfaces
the last known renovation of the church
was in 1479 botched partial repair work
in the centuries since then has caused
huge damage and now a hidden history has
been revealed before the solution we
have six angels of the war most active
force and we have the seventh one a now
part of the head of this angel was
missing it seems that they decided to
cover it in the eighteen forty forties
when they replaster the church just
seventeen years ago the church was one
particular bloody focus of the
israeli-palestinian conflict under siege
for six weeks with Palestinians wanted
by the Israelis holed up inside
now it's full daily with pilgrims and
tourists and soon this last corner will
be opened up to reveal to everyone a
fiefs most surprising find we consider
that as the the major discovery of this
program two fonts one for infants inside
another larger one used at a time when
it was adults who were baptized not
children they date he thinks from the
sixth century as part of this
restriction program you can see more you
can see the details of the details you
can go deeply with the history and the
meanings of the elements inside the
church you've become more attached to it
even more attached to it yes sure sure
no doubt under the altar is the grotto
here pilgrims come to the spot that
marks the beginning of Christianity a
star in the ground a point where their
Messiah was born
[Music]
this is yet to be restored it will
require coordination between the various
Christian denominations here and more
money both the challenges but they're
small given what has already been
achieved
mark stone Sky News in Bethlehem